we're also discussing these things as  though they're opposites when they're  communism and anarchism when in fact  they're two sides of the same coin  because they partake of the same false  anthropology which says the fundamental  political institution is the individual  which is not true and has never been  true the fundamental political unit is  the family and so people are not born as  the enlightenment of post-enlightenment  rationalists would have you believe as  individuals with a bunch of Rights and  entitlements but primarily though we do  have rights but we are born not as these  atoms floating through space but into  families with duties and obligations and  and so your love of your state and your  love of your country is an extension of  that filial piety because you have an  obligation to to respect your father and  mother